[Musique]
bonsoir mes amis quel beau dimanche
aujourd'hui avec gros ours
on a fait la grasse matinée et ensuite
nous sommes allés à la campagne comme le
rappelle le petit louis comme eux et
comme beaucoup d'autres enfants aussi et
nous sommes bien amusés hollande ou de
bien rigoler prêteront l'auront d'offres
et un bon repas décent vite voir nos
deux petits amis car ils sont revenus
très tôt de la campagne spécialement
pour nous voir j'y fonce pas trop le
rapport aux propos regarde comme elle
est belle cette sphère oui mais ils
affirment ils
mais non elle dans la maison ah oui
c'est vrai oui elle fait la soute fait
la soupe ou le type option était petit
il s'est tourné à l'aigre en fait je
sais il y avait tout plein de fleurs
oui c'est vrai et on en a ramené que
c'est pour cela faire une affaire où on
est allé chercher du lait tu vois il y
avait plein de petits cochons
comme celui-là il mangeait tout dans une
grande montjoire et y avait aussi dit et
sont ma foi très mignon et puis et puis
et puis il y avait des vaches dans
l'écurie
et puis ça qu'est ce que c'est mais
marche très bien ce monologue et et
c'est vous qui l'avez fait bien sûr je
suis sûr qu'on peut faire de la vraie la
ville avec ta yo yo poteau c'est vrai je
suis un gros nigaud ulysse n'arrête pas
de me le répéter
moi je vois deux enfants qui ont
semaines et qui sont bien fatigués par
leur journée à la campagne
un halo ou dodo
[Musique]
là j'éteins la lumière voilà bonne nuit
les petits pots ninh nord
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
mirabel et son frère petit louis dorment
déjà
à force de semer du sable j'ai bien
sommeil moi aussi le mot voilà patron
allons monsieur les nigauds en route
allons nous coucher nous aussi me faut
que ça me fait trop bon repas pas trop
au oui bonne nuit des enfants faites de
beaux rêves
à demain demain
[Musique]
oh